More people in the world currently suffer
from obesity than from hunger.
The world's longest piece of music lasts an
astonishing 639 years.
It is called As Slow as Possible.
There are currently more vacant houses than
homeless people in the United States.
When adjusted to account for inflation, John
D. Rockefeller was the richest man to have
ever lived, with a net worth 10 times greater
than Bill Gates.
In Los Angeles there are more cars than people.
The average four year old asks over four hundred
questions a day.
The population of Ireland today is still 2
million less than in was before the potato
famine, over 160 years ago.
Just as some people talk in their sleep, sign
language speakers have been known to sign
in their sleep.
Whilst Pixar was making Toy Story 2, someone
accidentally ran a Unix command which deleted
the entire film's data off their servers.
It was restored thanks to an animator who
kept a copy of it at home so she could work
on it at home.
Starfish can re-grow their arms if cut off.
In fact, a single arm can regenerate a whole
body.
Velociraptors were actually only about as
big as a modern day turkey.
Statistically, going to work is three times
more dangerous than war.
Shakespeare told the first ever "Yo mamma"
joke.
If you ever run out of candles, a single crayon
will burn for 30 minutes.
In 2008, pet hamsters were banned in Vietnam.